okay so for a long time people been
saying do over the gay wall do I open a
gum wall uh well we've gone half way
through we are at the way we just got
done with lullaby and frog land and
gotten up to that point uh this is a
weird 100 pen um it's like there's so
much to talk about and yet I don't know
how to put it uh it's one of the few
times where it's like I'm kind of at a
loss for words but I can do my best to
sort of sum up you know what I see here
well first uh that's how these gonna be
spoilers in this I think anyone who
watches this has probably seen it
um and I give it a lot of credit that it
is something that I've never seen on you
know TV or Cartoon Network I think it's
really kind of risky to put something
like this out how many up but there's
about ten episodes of these 11 minute
vignettes and they they do sort of tell
a continuing story you know it's kind of
like a roadtrip movie where they come
across different creatures and
characters and stuff it's just two kids
trying to find the way home and the best
thing I can think of while watching this
it reminds me a lot of the books of like
Alice in Wonderland Wizard of Oz the the
books uh lost a little bit with scary
stories to tell in the dark yeah it sort
of has yeah we're Wizard of Oz and
Allison wonder when we're very whimsical
magical and when you redo you serve got
like a bright colorful thing this is
definitely much more woods and dark and
chart kind of a folktale
yeah very folk tale is very like don't
not Grimm's fairy tale is like kind of
American like yeah additive yeah like
more like an American folk tale versus
like a Grimm's kind of though I mean
there do seem to be witches and beasts
but I just don't I don't get European as
much out of this no other that's which
is in you know America obviously a well
quote-unquote you know burned a lot fern
that's right actually that is a lie we
hung them ah yes society didn't burn
witches over here we hung those best so
we did it right that's why they didn't
come back yeah that's why you don't see
him anymore
must be the reason that's a lie we
killed innocent B that's what I'm sad
but now yeah um it's make you Salem
Pacific it's why those a miniseries
where it's the the best way I can kind
of describe it is that you remember when
you're like three years old and you
watch every day you watch like a movie
or you know even a cartoon show that's
maybe a little above your age and you're
not quite at the point where you
comprehend everything that's going on
but you're kind of just hypnotized by
and you're watching and you can assume
to yourself at some point I'll
understand this and claiming this is
Teletubbies for adults no no I I mean it
like like watching some like Return to
Oz when you're like three or four years
old or something like that we grew up
with that movie I know what you're
saying cuz it's all I can say I'm just
like I'm just watching and I'm just like
oh yeah you're just users hypnotic yeah
yeah it's just a strangely hypnotic show
even in the episodes where for a good
five minutes nothing much is going on
the the episode at the school where the
kids just playing outside with the
animals I'm just like there's like
nothing going on here but I'm just
mesmerized by most things we watch
whether they're good or bad we usually
talk a little bit through it and make
from Marx's tell me this were just yeah
I I mean we're just we we hardly said a
word we were just even after it's done
usually there's like a reactor of
ballast drains elsewhere it's like yeah
next I mean it's like and it's not a bad
thing I know it's not at all like we
were so hypnotized by we just couldn't
even say anything and I it's it's hard
to know what to say even now it just
yeah that's all I can compare to is like
there were there are a couple of scary
stories to tell in the dark where it's
just like oh what the hell was it moment
the old way with the ships the Gipsy
drum or whatever it was some folktale
about this girl who wanted a drum from
some other girl and the girl keeps like
saying you have to be mean to your
parents or something and
the mothers just like don't do that
because eventually I'll be replaced by
some angry mother with like a wooden
tail and a glass eye or something and
like it's this nonsensical story and so
she keeps acting bad the daughter keeps
acting bad and eventually she gets the
drum but she returns home and then it's
just like then she met her new mother
with the wooden Te'o and the glass side
it's like tons of ton that's it it's
just surreal and you're just kind of
like well I guess there was a moral
there but it's just bizarre and all of
these have that same thing it's like
there is a moral but it's just weird
that happens and yeah it reminds me
a lot of a cure Sawa's uh dreams if
anybody's ever seen that it's oh yeah
that's yeah it seems very strange in
individual stories where here there is a
continuing story and Ian arguably a
theme I think very basic morals but they
sort of end on these very strange notes
that aren't like and here's the
punchline and here's the moral here's
the whatever they're just sort of like
on these really weird we don't need to
impress you we're just telling you what
happened basis but what we're telling
you happen is so strange that should be
enough and we're just gonna let that sit
with you uh and I don't mind that
surprisingly it's because it's so sucked
in to its own strange world and it looks
very nice uh and yeah like I say serve
one of those movies or shows you watch
as a kid and you even though you're not
following it you're so intrigued and
you're sucked in and you think it's just
take out the part where you grow up you
watch it years later and it makes sense
uh just take that part out and just
accept the sir reality of it and it's I
it's challenging in a good way
like I can't say I understand everything
that's going on or why certain choices
are made in fact I'd probably argue I
understand very few of the choices that
are made but they're so intriguing and
so laid back and so original this is not
based on a book or story which really
shocked me this reads like a Victorian
children's story our collection I mean
with children's story kind of I'm comfy
animals in the school wearing the hats
and outfits and stuff I mean that just
sounds like a wins in the winter the
Willows type fingers a little bit though
I feel like there would have been more
of uh I don't want to say point that
sounds mean but like a direction where
you know what this is this is like
quino's journey for seven-year-olds
I think if you haven't seen you guess
yeah if you haven't seen quino's journey
it's a really great anime but it I get
that same vibe watching this and I do
from quino's journey it's like here's a
random travelogue and meets a bunch of
weird people and there's a little bit of
a moral to every story and sometimes he
helps the people out or sometimes they
help the people out sometimes they don't
and you get this weird sense of the
culture of everywhere they're going and
it's a world that very much exists in
its own strange reality like you know in
quino's journey just every land has a
weird quirk or some sort of weird yeah
they live by here it's like every
creature you come across or every place
is a different kind of creature like you
know one could be on a frog but one
could be you know a mansion run by this
crazy guy you know who didn't realize
that his mansion was connected to
another mansion and that both people
live in the mansion think the other is a
ghos I mean it's just the strange little
kind of fable I think my fare was the
pumpkin one
yeah I'm compassion uh yeah that I
school one was pretty good too actually
I will say this the animation is amazing
and it's always the little details that
sometimes you appreciate the most I mean
from the beginning I thought the
animation was really good but there was
one detail that I thought was awesome
and in the school one the school teacher
goes in front of a window in the
schoolhouse and as part of gather and
there's dust particles in the Sun beam
and I'm like that is a detail that only
like somebody who really is on top of
their game would catch you know not
watching it but animating it and being
like you know we're gonna set this tone
and the scene so much that there's going
to be little dust particles in the Sun
beam coming through the window and
that's amazing it is not you know what
I'm saying with like Alison one
wizard of oz' like the book The Wizard
of Oz movie has a very clear beginning
middle and end come across people
they're always on the books alike come
across just these weird rock creatures
or something and then they're on to the
next thing and it's like or someplace
we'll have some times I have a moral
some types of won't and that's just on
to the next thing it's the same thing
that I also wonder land where everyone
yes
yeah it's there's not exactly like
always a point or it's all coming around
to one thing it's just all right here's
some strangeness enjoy now we're keV on
to the next strangeness and it's like
does it create the world it creates is
so strange and the tone it creates is so
strange that you kind of feel it doesn't
even really need sort of the traditional
three act structure and I like a story
that can do that which it's like we
usually harp on stories that's like you
need a three-act structure which you
usually do but when you're so bizarre
enough and clever enough that you can
actually go beyond that I really respect
uh okay honestly each vignette I think
has a three-act structure but you know
what I mean like here's a beginning
middle end how do I put it like but if
you're talking about there's a whole
narrative from beginning to end so far
no it seems pretty random yeah like we
don't even know who their parents are or
anything like that all we know is that
he's got a crush yeah we don't even know
why they were lost in the woods or why
they're in the wood they know the blue
bird bit came up randomly just like and
I used to be human I loved Elijah woods
read em at just really I didn't know
that I'm pretty sure I would have
remembered that
did I know that no I didn't know that I
didn't know that which I saw had to
remind myself to wait did he know then
that he says it as well yeah um the
ending reminds me a little bit of
gravity falls every time I hear Elijah
Wood I think of dipper actually uh in
that part I do the first minute he was
talking I thought it was the same voice
acting it's and then it hit me am I oh
it's Elijah Wood who it not only does
that guy have a face made for cartoons
because he looks like a hobbit with the
big blue eyes in the but he's got a
voice made for cartoons um it's hard to
image it's hard to gather his age last
year I just finished up on a Tron
uprising the Disney cartoon and he was
amazing in that on
if you want another great animated
series that was better than the tromping
see whoopee
and of course Disney in their infinite
wisdom it's like hey this is really
awesome cancelled but yeah I was
watching that and I thought he was
amazing in that so I'm glad he's in this
now um we've got John Cleese maybe yeah
that had be Cleese I be I thought I
heard yeah I guess we got Christmas I
got Christopher Lloyd um as the woodsman
and did I hear James Earl Jones I swear
I heard him too but I did we didn't see
him in the credits so I'm not sure yeah
I thought it was seriously the the
bestirred this is the same uh these are
the same people who did like adventure
type pretty much and their credits are
certifying always clump together like at
the end of like an adventure tiny
episode yeah
wait these people weren't in them but
they just sort of clump them together
like in general these people are kind of
here kind of not whatever so maybe those
James Earl Jones I don't know if not
sounds a lot like him
uh but these people are often known for
just finding unique talents that are not
they use big voice actor names as well
but they don't always like for the main
people like they'll find sort just
various people that you've never heard
of or you're just are new to show
business all right
because I am d beat a lot of these
people I'm like lots of new comer as a
newcomer
a lot of writers like there's a ton of
writers on these you know some wrote
them all the way through others just in
and episodes it's a well-written show
yeah and I think part of it is just that
strange variety and I think because they
created an atmosphere and an environment
where you can just sort of do whatever
selfish if an episode wants to make
sense great if it wants to not make
sense great it again very much I could
venture time that can kind of do that um
so yeah it's I I really enjoy it it's
but not like a yeah I can't wait for the
next one it's sort of like it I just I
this is gonna take me somewhere else
beau no no no I agree ativ Lee and like
I totally can't wait for the next one
like when we're just like okay we have
to stop here do the v-log I'm a crap cuz
I just want to know where the hell this
is going it's one of those where how do
I put it like I like I love the Disney
Sleepy Hollow I think if we might it'd
be a lot of the one that
tavern reminded me of singing about the
place and yeah we started singing that
sagres like this totally reminds us of
Disney's Sleepy Hollow but it's all
those things where the whole thing like
you know the I think the other thing I
really like about it is just like
Disney's Sleepy Hollow just exudes
Halloween this fall and Chanti myself I
can watch this during fall yeah like
we're in the middle of spring down we're
watching this I'm like crap I would have
loved to have seen this in October or
November like this just exudes like
Halloween and fall and everywhere they
go with spooky woods or the the leaves
are turning or there's pumpkins or
there's beasts or they're you know it
it's just like Disney's Sleepy Hollow
that way you just get this feeling of
like fall now and what I was talking
about before with like I'm not
necessarily like you know I can't wait
to see the next one but I want to it's
very much like what I found like when I
was watching lost every time I couldn't
wait for the next episode to find out
what was gonna happen I was so sucked in
and then when it was all over and stuff
I don't really go back and re-watch them
I like even though yeah the ending suck
we all know that but you know as we
watch the hell out of it no I mean but
but that's why I'm saying uh and even
well gravity falls I would go back and
re-watch but I'm so excited next what I
cannot die without knowing what the next
one's gonna be we're with this one if I
don't know I'd be a little bit
disappointed whatever but at the same
time I can see myself watching all of
these every Halloween with the music and
everything in this sort of late nineteen
late 19th century setting I feel like
it's that first few minutes of BioShock
Infinite it reminds me a lot just
wandering around and there's just this
random music and you're kind of lazily
just looking at everything before stuff
goes to this kind of um it's a lot
like that it's just got this hypnotic
quality to it it feels like one of those
little shorts that like in those
machines we put a penny in you sir put
your eyes through and you see a little
short play as he you know I they went
and they travel to this area but then
this thing happened and they learned a
lesson and the end you know almost like
a silent film uh but yeah I really dig
that and I'm
are you shocked oh so many people have
like talked about egg and recommended it
and it's like as far as I know this
isn't like a gigantic hit but it's
really got this following I'm not
shocked that has a following I'm shocked
it has not as big and as fast a
following as it does that at all no no
because I mean we haven't seen the
ending yet but to this day we still
remember Disney's Sleepy Hollow and when
you look at the let's let's be honest
about Disney's Sleepy Hollow that is
five minutes of hardcore action and the
rest is just some singing and dancing
and not much going on and yet we still
to this day like and if most kids who
grew up in the 80s when they reran it on
Disney Channel all the time you know we
still remember it there's a reason it's
the atmosphere the atmosphere totally
makes it I think it's the same thing
with it nobody even yeah that usually
takes time for it takes time for people
to usually open up to that uh and I
guess I mean if you do it really well I
mean the first it had me from frog
playing piano like in the first five
seconds you had me from from but but
most people I get most people would see
like that first episode and be like that
was weird I mean like I don't hate it I
don't like it just that was weird and
then like sort of not go back to it but
you most likely will seem to keep coming
back to most people who like good
animation and good storytelling and all
of that and I think they would look at
the first episode be like I have to know
where this is going mmm and we keep
watching it I I wanna you know what I
think it's the same thing with Disney's
Alice in Wonderland it's just like you
may not know what's going on but you're
just like okay what the hell is next
like well with Disney's Alice in
Wonderland there was definitely like it
there were definite punchlines are
definite jokes which there's one or two
in this uh you know that some of the
lines the bird says are very direct this
is meant to be funny ah I love their
version of swearing by the way cheese
and crackers yeah Jiminy Cricket
um by me stuff like you know the boy
singing about like you know molasses and
potatoes that's that's not funny
but it's just so strange and they're so
into it
and it's just so sucked up in its own
little world we don't know I did think
enough people we I didn't think as many
people would get so sucked into that
bizarre miss without an obvious
punchline without an obvious wackiness
even though there's strange stuff it's
not I wouldn't say wacky
well not everything has to be spongebob
boy-oh no no but that's what I'm saying
I'm pleasantly surprised as so many
people have gotten into this I think
it's because I think it's because this
sort of stuff isn't out there all the
time
no that's okay it's what else is out
there
like this I mean obviously adventure
time to some degree even brighter more
colorful lanky it's in your every crazy
has a definite kind of plot that's going
on like this is different it's very
different uh and I really like that it
has caught on as much as it has and I
guess it's I like because it shows that
people have a little bit more patience
than I guess I this is more my Asians
this is more like the stuff you see
coming out of Europe or Japan or this
could have been like Secret of Kells or
song of the sea actually reminds me a
little bit of song of the sea just in
some of the animation and stuff but the
sort of things that kind of just run on
atmosphere and just it just sort of
whimsy but not like the honey was it's
like just sort of a natural whimsical
kind of thing going on like it runs on
cute and it doesn't seem insanely
manufactured I can watch that kid with
the stupid tea pot on his head singing
all day like it but it because it
doesn't feel for somehow it's just like
he's doing what he does so in this not a
lot of that out there everything either
right now has to have a plot or if it
doesn't it's too zany and over-the-top
or too ironic or are trying too hard
yeah it is kind of a sense of just
trying too hard like that you're right
there's no patience to it so this is the
rarity and I think people respond to it
because they're just like yes I want
this I crave this I want more of this
it's the same reason why I travel in the
hour and ten minutes into downtown on
the north side of Chicago to
see song of the sea' cuz I'm like
nobody's playing it out here and I'm
like I want something freakin like that
you know yeah there's plenty of stuff
that got released here that I enjoyed
you know like the lego movie and stuff
but I want something that's just patient
and weird and you know um not I think
you nailed it
ah so we'll get back to you when we
finish up the rest of these but it's
it's quite intriguing watch it yeah it's
um it'll definitely give you something
you haven't seen before um and and is
worth seeing so that sounded dirty it'll
definitely give you something you
haven't seen before and is worth see um
no we just went dark yeah
sorry you know for kids